okay leads are you live
ready to go thank you good afternoon
everybody and welcome to
this meeting of the um executive
item one is attendances and i have
received
apologies from councillor slater i'm not
aware of any further apologies
um item two is questions from members of
the public and there are none
item three are there any declarations of
interest
in any of the items on the agenda
no okay thank you um if we could move
then to
item four which is minutes and minutes
of the budget executive meeting on the
12th
of october can they be agreed please
thank you item
five is matters from council or overview
and scrutiny
committees counselor acton item 5a is
the pandemic scrutiny committee summary
report do you have anything you wanted
to say before that
only um in in relation to
as you will see it is a summary of the
work and recommendations of the pandemic
scrutiny committee since may
um and i i don't intend to go through it
all
i'm sure uh all members would have had
chance or
if they haven't they they will get
chance to to
to read it and i hope the executive will
find the report
and the recommendations helpful and that
uh you're able to respond to all the
recommendations
that's within the report can i also just
mention
um just briefly that uh
as you're aware scrutiny held two budget
scrutiny meetings earlier in
in the month and just to let you know
that
we're preparing a report and we'll
submit that report
to the executive in january well before
uh
the budget setting meeting in february
thanks councillor action do you want to
introduce the report then
sorry i i have are you happy with that
then sorry i didn't yeah
okay sorry my apologies that's fine so
um
i have read the report there are 18
recommendations i think
a number of which look um eminently
sensible but we will take those away and
make sure that a full response is
provided in due course and thank you
councillor acton for chairing that
pandemic scrutiny committee for us
obviously from
next month we will be reverting back to
our
more usual scrutiny processes with
yourself as chair of um core scrutiny
and children's and health screening
being split back up but i do want to
acknowledge the really useful piece of
work that that committee has done
during the um worst phase of the
pandemic i think it's right that we
return
to the usual structure in the new year
but it has been something that's been
very much appreciated by both the
executive and officers so thank you
to all members involved in that um
i think six then is the
council's poverty strategy councillor
please did i just before bringing
councillor with them in just have people
to check that they are
on mute i'm detecting some background
noise that would be helpful thanks
councillor whitman please thanks leader
and hi everyone yeah really pleased to
be bringing this to the
executive meeting so this is our
one-year poverty
strategy which you've all seen in the
the papers i'll just go through just a
little bit of background to the
to the development of this because some
of you will be aware that we
um through the traffic
ship were developing a property strategy
with partners prior to the the pandemic
so that work was was put on hold in
march and then we've picked this back up
in sort of september october time
to move forward on the basis of
implementing a one-year poverty strategy
next year and which i'll talk a little
bit more about in a second
with a view to them working with
partners um through next year
to develop a longer term strategy from
2022 onwards and as detailed in the
in the papers that you've that you've
all had and just in terms of the
the one-year strategy i mean one of the
things obviously we're all aware of is
that the position
facing um households across the country
including
trafford here is very volatile and
low-income households in particular are
particularly prone to
the economic consequences of the the
pandemic now it's hard to predict
exactly how that'll play out
in trafford over the coming 12 months
but we feel it's really important that
we bring this one-year poverty strategy
into place now so we can start to
anticipate some of those challenges
and be really clear as a council how
we're responding to the needs of
low-income
residents over the next 12 months and
their poverty strategy
um sets out our vision
for the borough in respect of poverty
and is
clear that we want to see action across
a number of different areas
including child poverty food insecurity
and debt and access to affordable credit
but also sets out how
important the role of the economy in
trafford and creating a more inclusive
economy in the borough will be
in terms of uh tackling poverty in the
short term
and the medium and long long term
um one of the things that the strategy
will also allow us to do
is establish a poverty action group and
also
a poverty truth commission and those two
bits of work will help us both kind of
implement
action to address poverty in the short
term over the the
lifespan of this of this strategy but
will also inform the longer term
piece of work um going forward for from
2022 onwards so it'll be really good to
get stuck into that work uh now and
going into next year
thanks leader thanks councillor whitman
thanks for
all the work you've done to pull this
together it is a a new strategy for the
council but an
important one um both in general terms
and particularly given the year that we
have had are there any
um questions or comments from members of
the executive
on this item
now any questions or comments more
widely if you could use the chat to
indicate if you'd like to speak
please
counselor welcome please
thank you very much uh councillor
whittem um
i think he said it's an excellent report
it's got lots of really good stuff in it
maybe one
omission that i would just ask about is
possibly um
something on the share you know more on
the sharing economy actually bringing
down the cost of living rather than
obviously you were worried about
people's incomes and that kind of thing
but actually making life cheaper
cheaper for people doesn't seem to be
really reflected in the report at the
moment but obviously hopefully something
that we can reflect more
in the longer term things like uh car
clubs repair cafes
credit unions more cooperative ownership
of large you know big ticket items that
kind of thing i think would be
would be helpful and hopefully we can
address that in the um
in the commission that you're putting
together thanks councillor
did you want to comment on that at all
yeah no that's
thanks councillor welton for that yeah
with we do touch on the poverty premium
and access to credit
in the the one year strategy so i think
that opens up the space for
consideration um of some of the things
that you
suggest going forward and there is
things that we can
do and some of which you've touched on
to reduce sort of the financial
pressure facing households kind of
reduce the the cost of living and reduce
outgoing so it's certainly space we need
to
to explore and i think we do acknowledge
in the strategy and under that poverty
premium sort of section some of the work
that we could start to do in that
in that space but it'd be a really
important area for us to develop further
definitely
thank you councillor whitson for that
i'm not seeing anybody else
indicate in the chat so um the
recommendations are as per the front of
the report both to note
contents but also to approve um
the one-year strategy is that approved
all right thank you
thanks everybody um so item
seven another very important item is the
draft local plan um regulating
regulation 18 consultation councillor
wright
please thank you leader
i am delighted to present the first
draft of the trafford local plan this
evening
after many months of work meetings
discussions and debates we have got to a
position where i believe this local plan
is now a plan for the whole of trafford
that will improve the life chances of
the less well-off
secure the housing that we so vitally
need make a significant contribution
towards carbon neutrality
and puts the correct checks and balances
on development that benefits local
people
before i summarize the detail of the
draft local plan i just wanted to thank
a number of people for engaging with the
process
these include members from across the
political divide for whom we set up a
cross-party consultative group
and both members of the executive and
labor group
my biggest thank you has to go to ruth
cook who is putting in a credible amount
of work into this process
not just by providing the technical
advice we've relied on throughout this
process
but also for the organization of the
various member groups we have brought
together
i would also like to thank the rest of
the planning and strategic growth team
including adrian fisher for their hard
work and advice throughout this process
you will note the local plan has been
laid out in specific sections that
cover both localities street strategic
locations for growth
areas of focus as well as policies
for example you will note that we have
chosen pomona trafford wallside
carrington
and our town centres as specific areas
of focus for both growth and
regeneration
there are eight areas of focus in total
where we expect the majority of
development to occur
we have also placed an emphasis on on
inclusion this is highlighted by our
policies where we expect residential led
development
to for example provide homes for social
rent
provide homes that that are accessible
and adaptable stand
are two accessible and adaptable
standards that meet the needs of that
meet the needs of those with
disabilities contributes to our zero
carbon strategy
provides accessible and improved routes
for both walking and
cycling inclusion runs through this
local plan
we understand this is a borrower of
extremes we have both some of the
wealthiest and some of the most deprived
wards in the country
good quality homes access to good jobs
safe and accessible places we believe
leads to a more inclusive and socially
cohesive borough
i just wanted to draw the executive to
some noteworthy policies within local
plan
which i think define this plan as
progressive inclusive
and fit for the opportunities and
challenges the next 15 years will bring
us
we will not support developments or uses
that we deem will have a detrimental
effect
on the health and well-being of
residents particularly our most
vulnerable residents
we will encourage and support
opportunists to increase enhance
our range in quality of educational
facilities
we will expect major developments to
utilize opportunities for
apprenticeships
work experience and access to skills
that benefit trafford residents
we will expect all developments will be
accessible and usable by all sections of
the community
we will support the provision of new
housing that makes as much
use as possible of brownfield land
we'll seek to achieve a target of 40
affordable housing across developments
on site
and spread across the site we do not
believe
in we we believe in inclusive places not
segregating people
any development of 10 or more units will
be expected to achieve 40
affordable provision subject to a
viability assessment
all new developments will be expected to
minimize carbon emissions
all types of development will be
expected to make provision for
electrical vehicle charging points
and new developments shall make
provision for tree protection and new
tree planting
the above mentioned policies is just a
short summary of the policies within
this draft local plan
with many more detail within the
document i ask that the executive
approves the report
thank you leader thank you
councillor wright are there any
questions or comments from members of
the
executive um if you can indicate in the
chat i've got councillor patel though
thank you thank you um councillor wright
just would like to echo you your thanks
to the offices that have got us to this
point um
i think there's some really exciting
it's a really exciting draft policy
planning policies outlined already i
think it's it's key for all
elected members that we now encourage
residents
to take part in the consultation process
i think it's a really great opportunity
to
open up our planning system which
impacts on on everyone's lives here in
trafford
um for residents so yes thanks to the
offices and
a very exciting um first step i think
thank you councillor patel um i will
move
then to members more widely um castle
jerome
please thanks
three main questions really um
this is a an enormous document how we're
going to ensure the consultation with
residents
is fair and sarah in just six weeks
and my second question is is hale town
centre given
enough prominence in this document i do
think it is a
a major town centre that needs focus too
um but also number three uh flooding is
becoming an increasing problem in
in navigation road area of ultragum um
and i'm sure many places across the
borough other local
plans are very specific about the
mitigation measures such as
green roofs and permeable pavement
paving
and i just wondered why this local plan
isn't so
those three questions really thank you
councillor right
consultation hail and flooding yeah i
mean the
the final two um questions you asked
more than welcome to obviously this is a
consultation uh councillor jerome so
more than welcome to add those comments
to any consultation that takes place
uh more widely on the um on the depth of
the consultation
um the details are set out in the in the
report as to how we will conduct the
consultation
i don't know whether richard wants to
come in with anything um to detail the
um anything else to do with the
the process of the consultation what it
will involve
richard any comments on on that thank
you councillor
obviously in present circumstances our
approach to consultation is that to be
adapted from the way that we would
normally do would normally do a series
of
in-person events this time we are
looking at online events but i think if
you look at some of the online
consultation that we have carried out
um this year including for example on
stretford
and aap and otherwise you can see an
evidence that we've able to do that in a
way that reaches a broad cross-section
of
the community and residents in the in
the
in the borough and that's something that
we'll intend to do
it is a long document we will seek to
break it down into
bite-sized junks that's why when you
look at it you see you can see the way
in which the policies
are set out with a clear policy focus
and the special focus and i think that
does help
us to be able to ensure that we're able
to articulate in a way that is
understandable to
to local residents thank you
um counselor right is of course correct
that if people have got specific
concerns they can feed it in through the
consultation process but i wouldn't like
to leave the particular
question of um what isn't what isn't
isn't a town centre
um hanging without saying that that is
something that we did consider at length
when we were putting this document
together um you know particularly the
status of parsington isolated as it is
as a community
and therefore having some very specific
requirements i think there is a there is
a danger
um in terms of acknowledging where you
draw the line with this counselor jerome
and so
if we were to include hail i think there
would rightly be suggestions that simply
sail more russian upon mersey
old trafford and of itself and
potentially other areas as well
and could come forward with legitimate
claims but of course we are looking in
the
um in the years ahead to develop um
local area action plans for each of
those um
areas the town centre plans um that we
are currently doing some further work on
for hail and sale
more rather village center plans um
being the first example of that
so so the local plan wouldn't in any way
undermine
that work and we of course recognize the
importance of all of our village centres
but councillor miss blackburn has a
quest that has a question
yes thank you leader um with regard to
new developments
will uh consideration be given to
trades people who who are going to be
living there so that they have
close access to their vehicles which
will store tools and materials
otherwise those residents will be
in a sort of an apartheid type setup
whereby
not in certain developments could you
could they
comment on that please i'm
not sure if counselor right understood
the question but i wasn't entirely clear
do you want to just
um say that again yeah yeah with new
developments
um i i'd like some reassurance that
um people who have uh materials and
equipments
in their vans are able to park close to
where they're going to be living
otherwise if the development doesn't
tell you then creating a sort of a
part-time setup for those those kind of
residents and could you just comment on
that please
that's the right still not 100
sure i'm clear on what you're asking
there counselor blackburn but
um from a by all means make the comments
via the consultation
uh if you talk about car parking at new
developments there is uh provision
within the local planned documents
uh that discusses the car parking um
uh requirements as part of any new
developments if that helps
i'm not absolutely sure that was what
you're getting at though so you'd like
to further clarify i'm happy to
yeah to listen to it but um it's just
the the proposed
uh developments off of talbot road
didn't
seem to um in the sort of the
the consultation didn't seem to um
include
parking close to where the the actual
homes were and i was concerned that
trades
people who have vans with materials
and equipment in weren't able to park
close to where they are living
and that seemed to be suggesting that
only people
who went to work on public transport
with a cup of coffee in the hand would
be able to live in a development like
that
okay yeah i think i think sorry sorry
leader i think i think we've probably
got the the crooks of the answer there
to be honest
um as i say if you if there are car
[ __ ] standards that are named as
this part of the local plans so if you'd
like to comment
make that comment during the
consultation i'm sure i'll be taking on
board thank you
thank you um councillor new grosh please
thank you i've got to say i welcome the
draft plan and it was uh
interesting being part of the
development of that it's great to hear
that
in its current form we aren't
considering using any
green belt it's entirely brownfield
provision my question relies
on future housing growth and i'm
aware we are required to use
the standard method uh for calculating
that
however i do believe we're allowed
unless under
exceptional circumstances to justify an
alternate approach
my question is um where do we
where would we consider and what would
we consider
would be those exceptional circumstances
to you to deviate from the standard
method for calculating future housing
need
to ask the right i'll bring you in but i
will say at the outset that if you were
unwilling to speculate i think that
would be acceptable
thank you you you're stolen the words
out of my mouth there leader to be
perfectly honest but i wouldn't be
willing to speculate at this moment in
time um
we are obliged to um to develop based on
the government figures as things stand
um and as i say this is a consultation
document
um so by all means add your comments to
that thank you councillor newgrosh
thank you i do think there might be um
some value richard if you just wanted to
offer any technical insights around the
housing number question just for the
record but if not it's absolutely fine
uh thank you leader yeah the housing
number is
set in accordance to a national policy
as councillor new gross uh identified
you'll also be aware that through the
gmsf
process that the local need that we are
meeting is below the nationally set
level because we've done that through
effectively the duty to cooperate
through the gmsf
um so i think it's it's as being pointed
out it's a it's a hypothetical question
not a position that we're having to face
um at the moment um but if there's uh
more detail than that as i said happy to
take that through the consultation
thank you richard okay i'm not seeing
any more indications
of people looking to come in on this
item um so it is as councillor wright
has reiterated
approval to god's consultation on this
but noting that if there are any
substantial changes that come out
to the draft local plan a further report
will be submitted
um for approval prior to commencement of
public consultation
so with that caveat um an approval to
consult on this and the three
recommendations there for us
per the cover page of the report can
they be
um agreed please
thank you before we move on to the next
item councilor wright did this but i'd
like to add my thanks to all officers
who've been involved
in this process ruth cook in particular
who has done an awful lot
of the um legwork on this but actually
colleagues in planning strategic growth
richard and all of his team that have
taken us on i do think it's an ambitious
document and it's it's one of which
um i think we can be rightly proud so
thanks to to all the members that have
been
involved in that on a cross-party um
basis
so moving on then if we can
turn to council right again for the
um civic quarter area action plan please
thank you leader this paper outlines the
regulation 19 requirements of the civic
quarter area action plan
as the executive will be aware the
regulation 18 version of the plan was
consulted on between the 5th
february and the 9th of april 2020 which
resulted in the order of 40 responses
further work has been on
i'm struggling a bit with that
connection
i'm going to assume that's not just me
um and so counselor right can you hear
us
yeah can you hear me you are back
um and i would suggest oh good try again
um from the beginning if that's okay if
you go again counselor right i'll pick
it up and we'll uh
we'll carry on but but do do um do feel
free to try again thanks no problem
thanks leader apologies for that uh
thank you leader this uh
paper outlines the regulation 19
requirements of the civic quarter area
action plan
as the executive will be aware the
regulation 18 version of the plan
was consulted on between the 5th of
february in the 9th of april 2020
which resulted in the order of 40
written responses
further work has been undertaken since
the regulation 18 consultation
this includes an up-to-date market
analysis
and viability assessment with the key
changes from this stage
to the stage we are at now listed within
this document
the civic quarter aap is a plan that not
only provides a strategy for housing the
employment growth in this area
but also provides a plans to enhance the
cultural heritage and measure importance
of the area
and fully realize the potential of the
civic quarter
i ask that the executive approves the
plan thank you leader
much much more audible counseling all
right thank you okay
um any questions or comments from
members of the executive
any questions or comments on this more
widely if members can indicate either in
the chat
or the raise hand function
no okay so there is only one
recommendation as per
um the cover page of the report just to
approve the publication draft
um plan and to um
consult for a period of no less than six
weeks on that so can that recommendation
be
approved please
thank you okay
the next item is the electric vehicle
charging points in trafford procurement
item
please counselor ad said
thank you leader can you hear me
yes thank you cancer watch for a second
thank you uh yes i'm really pleased to
be uh in this report here today yeah
and that the report follows on from the
one earlier in the year we
saw to look at stock market testing as
you will know from the report
as expected it has generated a lot of
interest with some eight companies
expressing
an interest in this work as you will be
aware this is a very fast moving
area and the technologies around
current charging that are changing
rapidly because past this work
we would need to ensure that whichever
model we go forward with
has the ability to adapt and with it any
equipment to suit the needs
as technology changes each model has
pros and cons
as detailed in the report with some
given as less control
over aspects that were partly working it
could help
to roll this out faster most important
will be whichever model we go with needs
to be able to work in our communities to
ensure the provision
of a on-screen charging provision to
help encourage those within the wall
street parking provision to consider
looking at an electric vehicle as a real
alternative
and of course the citation and
accessibility of these will be key
considerations to that work
in addition under section 4.3 you
you'll note that this needs to be
developed to ensure a fair
and safe policy for those considering
their own access arrangement
having discussed this on a number of
occasions now it will certainly be
challenging
and will need to develop clear policy
around this
now i'm also aware that there have been
some requests of course
but as we move forward over the next few
months
this work will have to be developed
alongside the overall strategy and
implementation
of the work we will of course continue
working alongside
transport for greater magnitude on
electrical vehicle charging
however the report has detailed gives us
some opportunities
to help support local provision with
some potential financial benefits for us
that might not be otherwise available
i've also asked
that we've consideration to raising with
other local authorities around gm
with this work as detailed in the report
as clearly
this would be beneficial to us in terms
of savings
around back facilities and stronger
support facilities
so with that leader i'll happily move
before and uh wait any questions thank
you
thank you councillor have any questions
or comments remember
the executive no
and council of coggins then and members
more widely
uh thank you chair and and and um
counselor
and um yes very much welcome this report
something
that is um i've been waiting for for
some time and
i think i'll start with the same
comments i made the last time we had an
ev
charging report to exec that i'm glad
it's here
we have been waiting for a long time
actually it answers very few of the
questions
that we've been asking so while i'm glad
we have answers to these questions it's
a very small
part of the jigsaw um
we mentioned it mentions in the report
that 19 of our carbon emissions and
traffic come from road transport
and clearly this is only one part of the
solution
but even then we're obviously looking at
a very very small part of this
this jigsaw and what we really want as
well as
as this um is actually some guidelines
for those who
live without on street park with only on
street parking
and it's something we've been calling
for for a long time
and these these chargers will be great
for those who live near them but we know
it's going to be a small number of
chargers
and they're they're not going to be the
the the full solution
and um and i'm just wondering when these
guidelines will appear we've been told
they'll be coming for
for some time and i'm sure i do get told
though the reports coming in in december
and yeah of course the report comes only
focuses on on one area
so i'm wondering when will we find when
will we get a bigger picture approach to
electric vehicles
that isn't just talking about this
particular procurement for a small
number of spaces
um do we have a time scale for these
actually being on the ground in 10.4 and
10.5 we have a time scale for when we'll
actually see these coming back to exec
um and obviously the government has set
a big picture
timescale you know they as i say we've
been waiting a long time
do we have any idea when we will be able
to see people charging on these
and we i've asked before about
trafford having a car club car clubs um
do all sorts of things they reduce our
parking stress
they um enable people to move families
to move from two cars to one car
or people to move from one car to no
cars and they make public transport
affordable
for people who sometimes need a car when
i've asked this before i was told well
we have to tie it in with our electric
vehicle procurement because we want our
car club to be electric
and i don't see any mention of that
coming back here so is that still on the
table
is someone still tying those two ends
together and and finally
how are we going to be this doesn't tell
us anything about again what's happening
on the ground how are we going to be
choosing locations
and we have people contacting us all the
time and i'm sure you're doing your
awards too saying
i've just bought an electric car i want
to buy an electric car i'm replacing my
car i want to go electric
and i can't because i live in a terrace
and i only have on-street parking
so um how are those locations going to
be chosen
um there's a last question thank you
thank you councillor
thank you yes uh so it's an interesting
thing for us
benefits around the different aspects of
the different model that we actually
choose in that respect there
so i think but once we see the results
with the cure within a stronger position
to actually roll
in terms of actually be able to discuss
where a lot of these gonna go on the
street
i think that they'll obviously be a mix
i think that's what i tried to read to
my comments obviously
uh if you have partners in this work
then obviously that
that there'll be some benefits to
actually choosing the popular places
where we can do particularly long-term
centers and so forth as part of this
work
we've got to make sure it comes to our
residential areas and it's actually
putting them in the right spaces as you
know around residence wherever it is
it is going to be a challenge in itself
because obviously
from all the difficulties there okay of
course that's where they're actually
going to
go i have to make sure that they're
actually available to all
uh we don't want to be in a position
whereby obviously we put
if we put them in front say an
individual's property that person then
thinks that's becomes
their personal type property so we need
to look at this
strategy and likewise where people
looking that i alluded to a minute
a few minutes ago where people will be
looking particularly say at their own
charging facilities uh
in that sense that's where that clear
policy which we need to develop
over the equipment and i don't see that
develop um personally by the time we get
into uh
the performance and actually start
looking at this by time we get the next
report
not a few more times actually like to
see a lot more detail of
that particular appointment so i'll be
put persuading discussing this with
officers once we get that detail and i
want to see that come out there quickly
but the uh the average children
obviously as you know we've had a lot of
discussions uh
at different levels including those with
uh the letters from going around with
transport for greater manchester because
they've been doing a lot of work there
was i was hoping that seeking maybe put
tyson we're all out with them
but well they are moving at their own
pace and obviously we want to pick up
the pace a lot faster
and do this as well i've got a report
here actually looking proposing that we
actually do
look at this ourselves as well as the
financial benefits that it could
potentially bring
it also means we can get them out a lot
faster than what would matter otherwise
able to do
obviously we still want to work closely
with transport for greater manchester
that's probably their key part in all of
this and
they will have number ones across the
area but it's going to be getting
into those best events first which the
uh tfgm wants might not be able to uh
be concerned because there might not be
as much fun a lot for benefiting those
community ones that's where
uh using the work we do we're actually
gonna be crucial in that respect
and i don't have a list of sites yet but
not the uh
doctors have one i think there are a
number of areas where we have that's
where we want them to go
i think it's that this work will roll
out once we choose our partner
with a number of things i've been
involved with recently it's not till we
get to the level where we actually
choose a partner
and so forth to go with we're actually
the chassis becomes much clearer
and once we've done that we can then
choose the type of equipment we want to
use i'll go with any partners we do
choose
we do choose a partner and then once you
get this type of equipment where they
can go
and and that's what that'll do until
they constraints we need to look at in
the local environment
i mean depending on what's happening on
the street
uh we managed to upgrade the utilities
under the ground
in that sense i'm not something that we
need to bottom out with that one there
obviously hopefully with some of the
residential so that should be less of a
problem because
if they're long charging policy long
charging devices
they're not going to use high levels of
electricity in in that point in a
shorter period
uh so i hope that i had to assume a
question i've got all the answers at
this moment in time but i'll ensure
that the next report comes back we can
have a lot more details
richard anything but i'm quite keen to
actually
visible within the report thank you dave
could you address the car club point as
well please oh sorry yes i have to saw
it
so i missed that point yeah yeah but we
have discussed that
in the past there and uh i think there's
been
some discussions as well but we want to
obviously call the electric ones and
it's something that i'll ask
see if we can bring back as part of the
next report i think in that sense of it
because obviously there's things around
if they're going to be on our land it's
obviously it's not an airline they don't
have any control over them
uh but obviously uh if they're gonna be
an airline if we want to try and
encourage them to be electric
and yes we should have picked it up as
part of the report and i'll make sure
that comes as part of the next report
there
i don't know which you want to add
anything we will make a firm commitment
that that will be
in the um government report yes i mean
that i'm not sure as well
can i just clarify so this is not a part
of the procurement conversation this is
a procurement conversation has gone on
without talking about car clubs is that
right
it might be a question that richard
could answer if he's
available yes uh yeah they're
they're they they need to be joined up
at some point but
they are separate procurements there are
a small number of people who provide car
clubs
they are not necessarily they are not
the same people who provide the
infrastructure
for ev charging points so once we've got
an ev
charging infrastructure we can start to
identify where that is going to be
located
we can then start start to talk to car
club providers and procure the cargo
providers and ensure that the car club
users have
ev charging points so this procurement
exercise is focused on
the on the in the charging
infrastructure
so to clarify this computer conversation
does not mention car club so it may be
that we choose
a a a supplier or a company that is not
really compatible with that
and that conversation hasn't been
happening but if there is a plan in
place to start a procurement for car
clubs
so there's been a a discussion with car
club providers that have been ongoing
for a period of time what we want to do
is shift that conversation so it's about
electric vehicle car club when we
started that conversation it wasn't just
about ev
we want to move that to being an eevee
um charging
car club um but there are there are a
number of providers of cackle who tend
to be
higher car providers what they're
interested in is the provision of the
car not necessarily the
the charging infrastructure so this
paper what we're looking to do is get
the charging
infrastructure in place um and then it's
that we can get
the user of that be that independent
users or car club providers in
thank you um i can certainly testify to
the fact that i am regularly lobbied by
non-electric
car club providers asking for meetings
and i don't take them
as a consequence of the fact that we've
got other intentions for
our carpal fleet in terms of being
electrified if possible councillor evans
please
thank you chair um slightly issue with
their
counselor toggings on these are going to
be small numbers they need to be large
numbers
and in the 10 years time we're not going
to we're not going to be able to buy
a petrol diesel car and i think it's
very important that we align
with gm on this because it will be
um wrong to be the max of car charging
points within gm
and possibly even trying to line with
cheshire east that we can at least
attract you wouldn't come from wilmslow
now
with a low you know a low charge you'd
be quite worried about heading from
wilmslow into altering him but we do
want to attract people from wilmslow
and and further afield so i think that
that alignment is
is key and i'm pleased to see the
demolition of the
uh hated template public lavatory
and with a view to installing it be nice
to get a timeline and when we're likely
to get some car charging points there
and and it's the timeline that's
worrying me so although i've said we
need to align
that delay in waiting for a perfect
solution i think potentially we might
need an interim solution because this is
evolving
so rapidly but it's the timeline we had
a commitment last year for 100 within
trafford
and i know i i can't even imagine we've
installed any you might correct me on
that but
and we do need to get crack on with this
so is there any idea of a timeline
counselor i've said
when we might actually see some
infrastructure appearing
i'm sorry thank you uh good question
council having to
obviously come back to the point
obviously that we need to get our
partner or
get this recording exercise done once
from there we can actually then be in a
petition to actually roll this out
i actually asked that obviously that
when that procurement when that report
does come back following the completion
of the performance exercise that we do
have timelines written within that
report there
that's going to be crucially important
mostly you need to get to this key point
apologize it's taking longer to get here
like a lot of things this year
pandemic has actually delayed aspects of
work also this is
uh this in itself i've had lots of
discussions around ev charging
and the problem with is it's actually
getting that sort of technology also
within the technological retards to make
sure we
get the right technology with this and
it's been so rapidly changing
we have been discussing with transport
for greater manchester yes of course we
have and those discussions will continue
with transport for greater manchester
and and whatever we can link up and
provide facilities between us
that will actually be a benefit to all i
think this did indicate we want to
it wasn't working at a fast enough place
for us to be able to do things locally
and in particular
in those residential areas where some of
the commercial companies
may be of less interest but we're
obviously where it's more about getting
people
onto science mapping about income
generation which
can be important particularly to uh
private providers in that sense so i
mean
uh i'll actually ensure that we actually
do when we get this report back
in the current exercise we actually have
a full timeline within that point there
i believe it's important yes and the
timeline not the government has brought
it down to
10 years time so it's going to be
rapidly probably do that
and i want to make sure we take full
advantage of it but as soon as we have
our
chosen performance in place there i'll
make sure that
just happened rapidly as you've seen
from the world that there's money's in
there for quite a lot of charging
facilities possible
and once that that will actually be key
and completely completely
looking over fighter and actually about
that particularly in the report there
and with the star performance that we
actually use and that'll actually
be able to test that across the board
and obviously i think this falls out
over the next few years
well without i think that will actually
widen quite a lot and there's obviously
generate an enormous amount of interest
that's part one we got
i shouldn't getting through that and
actually getting to the uh the system
actually right for us and the partners
working with us
and we actually have someone now who's
actually been helping us and advising us
locally in trafford
and and i think without that person it's
been a lot harder with that person who's
important and giving us this expertise
and then we're helping to lead us put
this report together so i'm
quite pleased with this i think there's
a lot to do and it's only the start of
the process
and recognize that they're going to make
that take longer to get there
i think we now need to show as soon as
this performance is completed
we'll see and i'll start to see a roll
out on that one and that's going to be
liaising
with us on that timeline must appear in
that next report so i'll make sure
being with richard that will actually
happen thank you
thank you councillor i've said um and
i think to to summarize both of the
questions that
that we've had there um nosy and got
this with my new portfolio hat on
the report that comes post-procurement
we'll have both clear timelines
and and car club updates in uh
um and richard will nod in a moment but
um but yes we we will make sure that
those are joined up because there is a
lot of
common sense obviously in doing so i'm
not seeing any other
indications of people looking to speak
um but we will
move to the recommendations the three of
which are on
the um cover page of the report can they
be agreed
please thank you
and so that brings us to talking of my
new portfolio responsibilities the
trafford
climate emergency progress report
delighted to bring the report and
recommend
the um appended carbon mutual action
plan
for approval um before i do so it's
right that i
thank and pay tribute to the work that
council has head has done
in this i am very much i'm coming to the
party late
in terms of the executive member input
into this and i would like to
put that on the record but also to thank
all of the members involved
in the task and finish group that looked
at
the council's response to climate change
also
just in terms of the purpose of the
report it's as per the recommendations
really
to update on progress made since the
executive meeting in september where we
brought the anthesis
report um to note and approve
the carbon neutral action plan and to
set out
our intentions in terms of governance
arrangements moving
forward probably worth just
reminding members of the wider
environment in which this document
sits in terms of the key strategic
documents that that we are looking to
align with it so
um it will tie in with our new local
plan it also augments
it's also augmented by the gm work that
is set out in the five-year environment
plan and some of the
gm activity that's ongoing that
complements this
is set out in the report so at the last
um
combined authority meeting for instance
i moved a paper on the public sector
decarbonisation scheme
um which will secure potentially up to
80 million pounds worth of investment
for decarbonisation of the
public estate across the conibation um
so it's really important that we start
to draw that stuff together
um and recognize the suite of work
that's going on
um at all levels really um you know
national
local and at gm level um but that and
thesis report that i referenced earlier
that set out five key areas where the
council could directly influence
emissions
um as set out at section 3.3 of the
report
and so they consequently as they are in
our um
direct sphere of influence feature
heavily throughout the action plan
and will be the primary focus initially
of our work
section 4.3 importantly sets out the
government's arrangements to help
coordinate it
and bring this all together and
crucially to get partners on board
including the business community um
too so as well as the overarching
trafford climate change and air quality
commission there will be resident and
business panels established to
inform the work um that we are doing the
residence panel will have
a specific role as well as advising us
and helping to
establish the first citizens jewellery
that we will have seen in trafford which
i think
is a really important piece of work in
terms of how we
engage with our communities on what is
clearly a very
important issue in terms of the business
panel
and i put this on the record now
publicly
um but she has agreed to it initially
the chief executive will be
chairing that for us um which i think is
positive in terms of her ability to
influence
um stakeholders in the local business
community so
there's a lot within the report but
actually
the key document is the appended draft
carbon neutral action plan
um and i think they are that document
is setting up very clearly that there
are short
medium and long term actions that we
need to take in order to
meet our ambitions for achieving carbon
neutrality in trafford we had
a monthly debate about that at the last
council meeting
and indeed um certainly the labour
amendment
did pick up some of the actions that are
in this plan um in in going through
council last week
so um i think as i said this is to know
and approve the plan
really and to begin to pull together
those government's arrangements
um and so with that i will move the
report and
if there is anybody from the executive
wishing to speak up at council outside
please
is it thank you thank you leader yeah
i mean just like to say yeah like
yourself i'm really pleased
i would like with this costas for
putting it together let's
please it's uh gonna cut its glass no no
no through a little bit fantastic foot
covering there's a gm level which is
logical that you took this over
a little bit out leading to a good
example of how we can get things done
locally
at that high level yeah i think the
report itself it covers everything i'd
hoped for unexpected and obviously as
you indicated it all done from the
previous uh
thesis report for executive interest
about that
it uh grow things up running parallel to
the uh
work that was going on obviously also
members weren't quite keen on that
some of those aspects there but i think
uh it's really
they held alongside they need issues
which is so important actually as you
indicate
and you simply just look at the agenda
tonight there are a number of items
after new generation that actually all
contribute in one way or another at
least here
last support i spoke to on eb charging i
have to say i particularly like the uh
appendix on that one i think it's a
layout and graphics make it really easy
to involve
and i certainly recommend it for what we
are trying to play this
skyline wide this is so easy to do that
in turn please pick up and i see what's
going
on and i think the holes around the
carbon neutral framework the
government's engagement
and national planning are very detailed
with a number of specific proposals
different short term that leading to a
long-term objective and that's i'm not
going to go into those problems if
you've done that and obviously
it's out there now i think uh for me of
all this uh
one area which i'm really pleased about
in there essentially that everyone calls
the government's engagement sections i
think
looking for our partners across this
area of the businesses the communities
i think we couldn't help to achieve any
of our targets without
this contribution together and what i
really do like as well i actually set
a vote for everybody in our community to
get involved within that one so i think
i'm really pleased with this
sort of and i think that's a great start
now and obviously i'm also pleased
obviously within that before it
obviously sets out
the main thing for cartoon which is
training at some point obviously
hopefully we'll be able to not just
follow up to councillors
and officers as these hail there i think
they'd like to see if we can actually
to a different organization start
rolling this out uh perhaps the
community groups and individuals to so
how they can contribute
and that's important that's gonna be so
important that we do this it's such a
big piece of work so
thanks for being report thanks for
watching the offices and yourself
i think it's a really really great start
i think i can't i know you'll be getting
on twitter but i think he'll as exec
members
and indeed all councils will have duty
to do our own parts in this we've all
got a wall to play in this so
i think it's down to yourself or people
itself is down to all councils and
you'll just get involved in that
actually make this work thank you
thanks counselor i've said um and i do
think your point about
um the report looking the action plan
looking good is
is well made and we do need to ensure it
circulated as widely as possible but
there is a cons
element to this that is about the
discrete section council website as well
which i've made clear
um is something that we need to see
fairly soon and i would not like
to see just the pdf uploaded i would
like those lovely images
to be just as
a web page so that's something that we
will
um look at to bring forward and make
sure that we are communicating on this
issue
appropriately as soon as possible but i
will bring in
councillor coggins first please thank
you chair and
thank you to um yourself and just echo
the um
thanks to cancer ad said for who has
recently handed over this portfolio
and yes obviously very pleased to see
this uh finally here
um a lot to welcome here um
residence panel the commission the
business alliance model
um and and really i think everything in
it is to be welcomed also just welcome
the
um announcement there of the chief exec
executive
chairing the business alliance which um
i think is an excellent
idea um there's a
big focus on the governance aspects and
how the different organizations will
work which is really important because
as the document technologies
the council is not responsible for the
majority of emissions in trafford and
of course this this um project um all of
trafford not just
that within the the council's direct and
sphere of control
and i suppose a few questions in
relation to
that and in terms of what the council
can control it mentions
the strategy for the operational estate
on page 12. i'm wondering if we can at
some point have a look at that or hear
how that's going
and what mechanisms are we going to have
for keeping on top of that obviously our
green motion that went through last week
it's calling for um well what we what
has been agreed now finally was six
monthly reporting of
of our emissions or good accurate
proxies for them
and uh so how are we going to keep on
track of that strategy
what will it be when can we see it how
we keep on track of it
and the dividing up other things into
act into different areas is obviously
very useful
and um the grounds for a plan it's not
in itself an actual plan
for getting to the council itself being
carbon neutral
it's kind of telling us what areas we
need to tackle and the sort of issues
there are in those areas it doesn't give
us the answers in a way it raises
questions
and one question is whether there's a
danger of us falling into silos and
really just raising awareness of that
and making sure that we are working
across these different categories
as well as focusing on on each
individual one
and so so yes so one question there
about
the strategy for the council's
operational estate and
and one question about mechanisms for us
keeping on on track of this and not
falling into different silos
um in terms of the
time scales um obviously the short term
here is defined as by spring
2022 and this came about as a result of
the
green party's climate emergency motion
in 2018 it's over two years with uh lib
dem support i
sorry and and um it's over two years
we the young thesis report tells us we
have seven years uh before our carbon
budget is used up we had nine years when
the motion passed we're now at seven
and if nothing gets done until spring
2022 we're going to be at what five and
a half
and we will still be on time according
to the parameters of this report
so i'm hoping that that spring 2022 is
an outside
um um estimate for those
early short-term measures and so
like i suppose some confirmation that
that's the case and some things will be
getting underway
much much sooner than that and one of
the things which needs to get underway
is the
commission which it says will meet
virtually before the end of december
i know the green party have a place in
the commission we still haven't been
asked who will take up that place let
alone notified of a meeting so i find it
hard to believe that that
is going to happen by the end of
december so just again wondering are we
already seeing some slippage
in these already extremely late
timelines
and and finally a question about
reactivity and for example it talks
about multimodal logistics and
the green party flagged up government
funding for cargo bikes
in business use last year and the
council chose not to take it up
are we going to be there will be lots of
pots and money coming up for
green and environmental and carbon
reducing measures over the next few
years
and have we got the flexibility to
respond quickly when these opportunities
arrive
thank you thank you
councillor cobbins so there there is
quite a lot in there obviously in terms
of the silos
question i think that's a really
important point it's something that
tasks me a little bit in my thinking
about my greater manchester role because
the way that the green city region
partnership is set up
is that there are a number of challenge
groups looking at specific areas
um which then raises the threat of silo
working obviously we
hear regular reports and and try to
avoid that where possible we very
deliberately at this point not gone for
that here
we've set up essentially convening
committees
to enable those sort of cross-cutting
and all area conversations to take place
and i'll be really interested actually
to see how that feels by comparison to
the green city region partnership model
because you're right that is that is a
distinct possibility if we're not aware
of that
and is is inherent in the way that we
structure the
approach on the operational estate um
obviously there will be the regular
reporting but clearly the strategy
around that would be something that i
would like to see as a regular item
at the um climate change and air quality
commission so i don't think there's any
issue with that being almost a standard
standing item on the agenda there
because that is something that is
directly in our influence to
a large extent and so certainly
something that we would want to be
getting on with to the same um to the
same
end really that question of getting on
with things
i should take responsibility for the
spring 22
date that is in the report um and that
is because i said that there needs to be
a stop date
on these early measures and so you
should very much view it in that context
that that is not when
we are looking to start this work that
is when
um all of these things need to be
underway or if they are things that need
to be dropped into
place completed so clearly some of the
work would be ongoing
other things such as establishing the
various commissions etc
is is a a one-off action um
with ongoing consequences so it is a
stop date in terms of if we have not
seen
a start on all of those short-term um
objectives by then then we have a
significant problem but no it is not my
intention to sit for 18 months having
not moved forward with any of those um
items thinking i've got until spring
2022.
that said it is fair that due to
actually issues with my diary it's
likely to be january
that we have the first meeting of the
commission um
so so that is a fair comment that's
something that's happened just as a
result of the portfolio change to be
perfectly honest that it's come to me
i um hopefully understandably have less
availability than counselor
um but but clearly it is something that
that is being sorted for january
at the moment it will certainly not go
past that and i think
i think the last the last question is an
important one about reactiveness rather
than proactiveness
in this and no we would not ordinarily
want to be turning down pots of money
there is an important point about the
overlapping
work that can take place at a gm level
so for instance i referenced the
gm bid to the public sector
decarbonisation scheme earlier
there was a similar scheme specifically
to retrofit
um housing of people with low incomes
that went in from gm so i'm not
suggesting you're not cognizant of that
when you say that councillor covings
because clearly
you will be but i think it's important
to say that we are regularly bidding and
that the vast majority of papers that
i've moved in my role
as green city region lead over the last
18 months have been about
bidding on behalf of the whole of the
connotation
for various pots of funding that are
available if we are missing things i
know you will point that out to me
and we will look to take advantage of
any funding that is available provided
that it's something that we think that
we can
manage but there need to be a good
reason not to and but i think
certainly a lot of those bids that we
put in do go in
at a gm level i think i have two at the
last meeting and i've got at least one
if not two
at the next combined authority meeting
this is an important space
the money is slowly and not to the
degree that i would like it starting to
come through
um from government now to to really
tackle this
issue head-on and we need to make sure
that we're not missing out so it is a
fair point well made
um counselor miss blackburn please
thank you leader um in the document
point
1.3 regarding natural environments and
water
in trafford would consideration be given
in promoting the use of grey water
in domestic homes for usage in say
toilets
so i have to be honest it is not a
specialist area of mine
that particular question i don't know if
richard has a
view on where that may or may not be up
to and the limits of
the realms of the possible with that
i think at the moment we're not ruling
anything out if there if there's a
a feasible way of doing that in a
practical way of
doing that it's not an area that i know
a lot about um grey water for use for
sanitation but it's certainly something
we can look at
okay thank you thank you um
i will apply for some re-education after
this meeting
[Laughter]
and then i've got councillor acton
looking to
come in as well yeah just just briefly
uh leader i think um you know i really
do
welcome uh this comprehensive
report i think much of the
recommendations
of the stupid scrutiny task and finish
group
has been included in in that and i think
that's
encouraging for for that
task and finish group and i i like the
fact that you've taken on board
uh the friends of the earth 31
recommendations for
local authorities and i think if we can
deliver those
um we we will be making some huge
uh progress so i'm
really excited about how we're going to
you know uh take this forward i think it
will be a challenge
uh but i think it is a challenge that we
in trafford
are up for so thanks very much for
bringing the report
thanks counselor and it is um
to use the word that i told councillor
coggins i didn't like in writing
last week a massive massive piece of
work and i think we all appreciate that
um you know and i understand that there
will be some members for whom we can
never go quick enough or far enough on
this but i do think that this is a
really important
starting point in terms of having a plan
that is not a plan to carbon new charity
it is a plan based around the actions
that we need to take
to set us on the journey to that and i
appreciate that but i do think this is a
really important milestone
and so i would like to have my thanks to
all of the officers that have been
involved in bringing that together
um as well so on that basis the
recommendations are as
per the report can they be agreed please
all right hi
thank you item 11 is the treasury
management mid-year performance report
for 2021 councillor ross please
thank you leader so this is the mid-year
report which was presented
to accounts in audit on the 26th of
november
and it's here for noting this evening it
provides a commentary on the debt and
investment
activity for the first six months of
this year um
there is an executive summary on page
three of the report um
and it obviously takes into account the
impact of covid
um which is hitters and dominated us for
for the first six months so i draw
particular attention to the
loss of the airport dividend which is
mentioned in the report
there's been the lowering of the base
rate of the bank of england which has
had some
impact on the returns we have on some
investments
the outlook for the next uh six months
remains uh
uncertain um we have covid which is uh
i've seen some developments this
afternoon
sadly and and also the huge question
mark over whether we're going to have a
deal
with brexit or not which of course will
have some impacts on
on this part of our work in the council
as well however
i'd like to draw the executives
attention to paragraph 7.3 of the report
on page 13 um where
our in-house treasury team have once
again
been judged as offering a high level of
assurance
and there were no indicator prudential
indicators or um
requirements that were well we complied
with our requirements and there's been
no breaches of indicators so i'd just
like to thank
the treasury management team very much
for their continued proactive work in
this area
and to have so many years of high level
reassurance is very assuring
for us all thank you
thank you counselor ross any questions
or comments from
members of the executive
no any questions or comments more widely
no okay so the recommendation
is just to note the activities
undertaken in the first half of the year
can that be
agreed please thank you
um and then item 12 is the last
substantive item on the agenda
which is the report on complaints
determined by the ombudsman
bill 2019 20 and the pleasure force to
council the ross
thank you again leader this report
provides an overview and summary of the
ombudsman's an
annual letter for complaints received in
2019-20
the total number of interactions with
the ombudsman for that year stood at 125
the number of complaints received by the
ombudsman was at 74
the number of complaints upheld was at
19.
a breakdown of the subject matter of
upheld decisions is contained in the
report at section 4.6 and a breakdown of
the resolution
determined in respect of each upheld
decision is contained in in the report
at section 4.7 um
you'll note there's the public interest
report and
this is where there are systemic or
multiple issues in the same service area
during 2019-20 and the ombudsman
investigated and upheld nine complaints
relating to waste management and waste
collection issues
six of the the waste collection
complaints related to multiple service
failures
this concentration of issues was deemed
by the ombudsman to
warrant a public interest report
covering six of the cases
the report was publicized in the local
press and required a formal report to
members it was considered by us at the
executive on the 20th of july
and it being noted that the council was
proposing to abide by the terms of
all of the ombudsman's recommended
actions and please say on the 14th of
september the council received
correspondence from the ombudsman
welcoming the action taken by the
council
and confirming that the ombudsman was
satisfied that the issues relating
in relation to corporate processes and
individual complaint remedies
had been satisfactorily completed so i'd
ask that the
executive note this report
thank you counselor ross are there any
questions or comments from members of
the executive
no any questions or comments more widely
on this
no okay the report is just for
noting can that be noted please
thank you okay we've got no items of um
urgent business so just um thank you
very much everyone for your attendance i
don't know if i'll see you before now
but it is the last
executive meeting pre-christmas so so i
hope everybody has
um a good and restful um break
this year i think we've certainly had a
lot on as a local authority all of us so
um massive thanks to everybody to use
counselor coping's word again
um and just uh take care stay safe
and if i don't see you before see you in
the new year thank you
i